[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the President of the United
States reportedly insists on being
brought to buckingham palace alongside
the Queen of England in a golden coach
drawn by six royal white horses like
goddamned Cinderella like a man unaware
of the security nightmare he will create
like a man unaware of the massive public
protests that all the kings or in this
case all the Queen's men and all the
Queen's horses might be able to keep
nonviolent might be able to contain but
cannot keep from happening when the
Times of London reported this latest
evidence of the Nexus of narcissism and
madness meeting inside the addled brain
of the demented man a minority of our
voters have cursed us with it caused
barely a ripple here because it was only
the 15th or 16th craziest thing Trump
had done that week reminder the
newspaper reporting this quoting
security sources and making references
to London's Metropolitan Police and the
u.s. Secret Service is owned by trumps
newest hanger-on Rupert Murdoch this is
not a story designed to harsh Trump's
buzz this is reality so real that even
Murdoch gets it the Times reported that
quote the White House has made it clear
it regards the carriage procession down
the MAL as an essential element of the
itinerary for the visit currently
planned for the second week of October
the story co-written by the papers crime
and security editor dripped with
warnings as recently as 2003 Vladimir
Putin's state visit saw that foreign
leader and the Queen ride the seven
tenths of a mile with the carriage top
down but six years ago President Obama
had the presence of mind to thank the
British for the option of the ceremony
but to ride in his own armored limousine
even when the President of Mexico and
the Chinese President visited separately
in 2015
each had the common sense to ride in a
closed carriage it is not clear that
Trump has even agreed to that if he is
in a golden coach being dragged up the
mail by a couple of horses the risk
factor is dramatically increased the
Times quoted its primary security source
as saying there may well be protections
in that
coach such as bulletproof glass but they
are limited in particular it is very
flimsy it would not be able to put up
much resistance in the face of a
rocket-propelled grenade or high-powered
ammunition armor-piercing rounds would
make a very bad show of things but we're
not even talking about those serious
scenarios this is a president who would
not go to throw out the ceremonial first
pitch at the Washington Nationals
Opening Day baseball game obviously out
of fear that he would be booed this is a
president who has yet to appear anywhere
in public in which he might not loudly
be cheered this is a president who
collapses into paranoid accusations of
paid agitators when protesters demanding
that he release his tax returns force
him to alter his motorcade route from
his fantasy land of a golf course he
owns but can charge the taxpayers each
time he uses it to his other fantasy
land of a country club he owns but can
charge the taxpayers each time he uses
it this is the world's ultimate
snowflake living inside the world's
ultimate snow globe of his own creation
to prevent the slightest chance that his
delusion that he is universally beloved
will ever come into violent contact with
the reality that he is hated allegedly
insisting that he ride to the palace in
a golden coach moving so slowly that he
would have to hear and see at least some
of those who despise him for as long as
ten minutes 20 years ago I had a stalker
and while I worked ironically then for
Rupert Murdoch the woman appeared to be
getting crazier and crazier now for
everything else they do wrong Fox does
protect its employees from stuff like
this Murdoch himself gets about one
serious death threat per day his head of
security a former Scotland Yard chief
told me after he had flown from London
to Los Angeles to coordinate a game plan
to keep me safe he had assessed my case
on the plane and he said that while he
did not suspect that the woman was going
to turn to violence he wanted to enact
several protective measures because her
behavior reminded him of the story of a
prominent actor who was being
unknowingly stalked by a woman fan
this woman's delusion about the actor
was different than most of them she
didn't need to actually inject herself
into his life she was content to simply
mirror his life if he spent the weekend
in say Miami she would weasel the
information about where he was staying
and what he was doing something at which
stalkers were far too adept and she
would go to Miami herself she would stay
at a hotel near his hotel she would
follow him at a discreet distance
never once would she interact with him
but on Monday morning she could go home
and go to work and say of let's call him
Mike Mike and I were in Miami we went to
South Beach we even saw that funny game
you bet on highligh when all this was
over her coworkers were absolutely
astonished everything she had told them
about Mike was factually correct and
rich in detail they never realized it
was only literally correct Mike had
indeed gone to Miami and South Beach and
highligh and this woman his stalker had
gone to Miami and South Beach and
highlight and the parts she left out
were she had stayed a hundred yards away
from him at all times and he never knew
she existed the stalking ended Murdock's
head of security told me in Minneapolis
or somewhere when Mike left his hotel on
foot and his stalker followed at a safe
distance and then suddenly Mike realized
he had left something at his hotel and
he turned around to go get it and the
stalker was faced with disaster Mike was
now approaching her she couldn't run
away that would be admitting to herself
that Mike wasn't actually her boyfriend
she couldn't cross to the other side of
the street
she couldn't stop to introduce herself
she certainly couldn't let him walk past
her without as much as looking at her
the entire elaborate self delusional
fantasy was about to crash down upon her
unless Murdock's man said that as soon
as Mike got within a few feet of her
this woman who he had never met and who
had never contacted him but who had
built a complicated and intricate and
expensive relationship with him saved
herself from the confrontation with
reality the end of her world in the only
way left to her she reared back and
punched Mike in the face she could now
smile and explain to the police to her
co-workers to herself that she and Mike
had had a fight and they had broken up
in our little nightmare course Donald
Trump is Mike's stalker and Mike is the
reality in which Trump the stalker is
failing and old and paunchy and fooling
a thousand fewer people right now than
he fooled an hour ago a reality in which
the world mocks him and the politicians
use him and his judgments are entirely
wrong and those closest to him try to
calculate the exact date it becomes to
their advantage to sell him out over
Russia and impeach and jail him and
mostly mike is the public that hates
Trump the stalker the public that Trump
the stalker has decided to expose
himself to from a slow-moving golden
carriage on the way to Buckingham Palace
in October what happens when reality
approaches Trump and he cannot avert
that confrontation what kind of punch to
the face does a forted stalker throw
when he has nuclear weapons resist peace
by the way if you enjoy these I am proud
to announce that coming in October my
book of these commentaries called Trump
is effing crazy it'll be available
wherever books are you know available
you